yeah because all that we used to do you
you'd clock in
like with like a yeah like it would
machine it with like flintstones yeah
like the flintstones
did you did you work george oh yeah i
always worked
farm now i always worked for my parents
mostly uh since they always they should
give me a job
i wouldn't couldn't work other places at
home but uh in college i think my
favorite job was the cynics gas station
night shift in walmart washington i was
there a summer
and that was just the best because you
didn't have to give a [ __ ] at all
you ever get worried that like you're
gonna get robbed
uh i think he was hoping for that
experience no um
you know whenever i got robbed by my
buddy uh you know a six-pack could be
waiting for me out front and i'd be like
tell my buddy hey like uh the other guy
working like hey
i gotta sit i'm taking a ten minute
break out front uh
can you cover this bad employee
you just do [ __ ] a man how you used
to steal from the [ __ ] no no no walla
walla washington if anybody else stole
you
it's not worth your life you're not a
[ __ ] up employee my friend oh yeah the
are you laundering money from us
yeah hey look at us right now are you
taking money from us
no sir you don't have principles on
i got principals most of the time i
wouldn't i don't you know i don't steal
ever as a kid did you ever do it no i
mean yeah as a kid i used to shoplift i
didn't steal
i did somebody else yeah if somebody
else took it i wasn't going to like
report them
i did i [ __ ] stole yeah because i
didn't really have money growing up and
i really
liked um where were your morals you know
who are you
i really wanted a couple bomber jackets
that like my family could not afford
when i was in high school i only stole
from like
big corporations so that makes it good
yeah makes it real
like i never would steal from you from a
mom and pop shop that's horrible
yeah but from macy's yeah that's
socialist yeah you're a good socialist
see
yeah i would never do that but yeah i
would [ __ ] steal like a nice jacket
or two
and i never got caught could i get in
trouble for this
yeah macy's are sponsored yeah yeah yeah
no it's all fictional
she never stole nothing she would never
do that and if it was someone's birthday
that i really cared about and i didn't
have the money i would yeah i would
steal go to dillards
yeah i mean i wonder what that i mean i
wonder
if like i always thought if i grew up in
nazi germany
do you think about that a lot no i was
in the no i wasn't still
broke and i was and i was like you're
going to be
you're going to be in the military and
you're
you know you're just conditioned you're
going to kill
jews yeah would i do it
would you i don't i don't know i don't
know i don't i would
i would hope to think that i wouldn't
but you know i've been watching a lot of
documentaries about war
and even like american soldiers coming
from
kids from the farm yeah
these dogs are going crazy i know man we
can't win
might as well take a break now from
brooklyn brooklyn
and heavenly sheets for your heavenly
body
you guys my brooklyn sheets are the best
most comfortable sheets
i've ever slept on period